Speaker 1: Okay.
The continued comedy of errors that also has
a major humanitarian death toll.
Right?
So we don't want to merely call it a comedy
of errors.
Russia has apparently shot down their own
$36 million bomber jet an airplane.
This is according to Ukraine.
There's a Newsweek article explaining it.
A $36 million Russian sue, 34 bomber was reportedly
shot down by Russia's own forces over Ukraine's
eastern Luhansk region, according to Ukrainian
media outlets.
Yesterday, the jet was reportedly down near
Olszewski, a city in the Luhansk region.
This is where the war is currently focused
and Olszewski is currently under the occupation
of Moscow backed separatist forces.
A video and images shared by the Strategic
Command of the Armed Forces of Ukraine on
the Telegram messaging app appear to show
the charred remains of a Russian SU 34 fighter
bomber.
Now, there is there's some confusion about
this because there were reports that the picture
of a non destroyed bomber is not actually
of the se you 34.
And there's some debate as to whether the
reporting is showing the right planes or whether
the reporting is describing the right planes.
It appears to be that it is an SU 34, but
that some of the images are not actually of
that plane, which makes you wonder, you know,
it makes you wonder a number of different
things, although I believe that this picture
that I'm showing you is of the S2 34.
You know, these types of accidents actually
do happen in in war.
It's not the strangest thing.
And when you get over 100 days, right.
I mean, we're into month four at this point
of a war where neither side is dramatically
well-organized when it comes to air warfare.
There are.
There's similar looking equipment on both
sides.
It's not the most unheard of thing.
But at the same time, we don't currently know
exactly how this plane was shot down.
Was it shot down by ground fire?
You would think that any air defense missiles
would be checking for identifiers where planes
have an identifier.
I guess if the identifier system malfunctioned
or if it didn't work, maybe Russian troops
thought this was an enemy bomber and they
shot it down as a result.
But it's a good opportunity to kind of zoom
out and talk about what's going on in Ukraine.
Bigger picture and it's not good.
And I've I've spoken with you before about
how the stories that make good stories for
corporate media are stories that have a relatively
clearly defined beginning, middle and end.
And if you think back to coverage of the Iraq
war in 2003 and the lead up you had making
the case for the war, that was a clear like
a pre war phase.
And that included the testimony before Congress,
which included faulty intelligence, as we
now know.
It included George W Bush making the case
and ultimately George W Bush announcing the
start of the war.
And then it went to missiles and the entire
thing, the actual meat of the war coverage.
And then you had the Mission Accomplished
banner.
And even though after that is when most of
the civilian and military casualties took
place, after the Mission Accomplished moment,
there was less coverage of the war as an event
that is ongoing.
It became background at that point.
And this is why and I know many of you have
heard this already, but I think it's important
to understand and for me to explain how a
lot of these corporate media narratives kind
of work.
If you have a story like Hunger Deaths among
African children, which is sort of like your
prototypical tragedy in the sense that it's
always going on and there's a question of,
well, when and how is it covered?
It's ongoing.
And this is why the constant deaths of children
from hunger in Africa don't get the attention
in Western media, as one or two people are
killed in a school, shooting as an example
doesn't mean any of the deaths are any more
or less tragic.
And in terms of prevent ability, that that's
a whole other conversation to have as well.
But with the invasion of Ukraine by Russia,
we are now.
Kind of in that middle phase.
And that middle phase can be very, very long.
And at this point, you can make the case that
nothing new is happening now.
Every time bombs are dropped, every time an
apartment building is bombed, every time people
are killed, those are new things that are
happening.
It's just as tragic.
One person, 101,000 is killed as when it's
person number one.
But the stories start to blend and people
start to say, well, weren't they already in
the Luhansk region?
Was this the Donetsk or what was it?
I think the the the infirmary or the nursery
was already bombed, was, oh, this one's in
a different place.
And so the coverage we are seeing in corporate
media starts to reflect that prototypical,
prototypical for independent shows like ours,
the challenge becomes how to continue covering
it, given that the resources of shows like
ours to have people on the ground are dramatically
more limited.
And so to a certain degree, we are reacting
to the coverage that is taking place, which
is certainly diminished at this point.
But the latest news is that that this is sort
of the individual element of the story.
Russia apparently shooting down one of its
own fighter jets.
And, you know, we could we could call it a
comedy of errors and stop there if it weren't
so tragic.